Hollywood loves adapting books into
movies which only makes perfect sense
there's already an existing fan base and
an outline for the script to follow
piece of cake right unfortunately it
doesn't always make for good movies as
the strengths of one medium don't always
carry over into another while there are
plenty of bad books that make for bad
movies the real tragedy is when a great
book is adapted into a mockery of the
source material from grim and complex
works that were turned into brain-dead
action flicks two children's books
turned into sleazy comedies here are
great books that were ruined by terrible
movies the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen Alan Moore is rightly
considered one of the best comic book
writers of all time and the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen is a perfect
example of why following a group of some
of the most famous figures in literary
history the series is a densely
constructed work that belies its obvious
high-concept Moore has frequently been
outspoken about his distaste for
adaptations of his work in general but
the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen is
in a league of its own on the positive
side the lead was directed by Stephen
Norrington a few years after he'd helm
played and it starred Sean Connery as
Alan Quartermaine unfortunately that's
about the last of its positive qualities
Connery cost so much that nearly
everyone else in the cast was a no-name
actor and the script deviated
significantly from the comic even worse
was the addition of Tom Sawyer
supposedly to excite American audiences
but Americans were not excited to see
the film nor was anyone else it was such
a disaster that Connery retired from
acting and Norrington announced his
decision to quit Hollywood Gulliver's
Travels in the realm of satire Jonathan
Swift is an old-school over-the-top
master of genius parody so when adapting
his work you should probably select the
lead actor who subtlety feeling is
unrivaled Jack Black despite as many
positives is not that actor in casting
him in the lead role of 2010's
Gulliver's Travels is only one of the
many mistakes this movie makes the film
retains almost none of the books clever
writing and winking references instead
relying on outlandish performances and
easy jokes despite negative reviews the
worldwide box office was actually decent
unfortunately that probably now means
that Jack Black putting out a raging
fire with his urine is the only frame of
reference many people have for
it's best work
valerian and Laura lein while there are
plenty of poorly made adaptations by
film makers who couldn't care less about
the source material passion projects can
turn out just as badly that's what
happened with Luke bosons valerian and
the city of a thousand planets an
adaptation of the long-running classic
French sci-fi comic balerion and Laura
lein the Sun had been a fan of the comic
for years and its influence on his
filmography is obvious but his valerian
adaptation stripped away the comic slice
style and replaced it with a sloppy
poorly paced rollercoaster ride while
the visuals are beautiful leads Dane
DeHaan and Cara Delevingne delivered
wooden performances that seem more like
auditions than a final cut
critics were harsh in the box office was
so underwhelming that it's unlikely
we'll ever get a sequel The Giver the
best adaptations understand that any
changes from the source material should
be made for the good of the new medium
but the makers of 2014's The Giver may
have gone a little overboard when
switching things up the novel follows a
twelve-year-old boy named Jonas who
becomes the receptacle for all of its
society's repressed memories and
emotions it's a slow burn that's heavy
with symbolism and a largely internal
conflict with very little action but the
movie ages Jonas up to 16 gives him a
love interest and Sprint's from plot
point to plot point with manic pacing
the intent might have been to keep
audiences from getting bored by weighty
conversations and internal monologues
but the end result is a movie that looks
identical to all the other dystopian
young adult franchises we need sameness
don't you think oh I completely agree
still it's awesome yeah Eragon following
a young farm boy who hatches a dragon
from an egg Eragon was a massively
popular novel fans thrilled to the
detailed maps and complicated
relationships between various factions
unfortunately anyone hoping for an
adaptation on the level of Peter
Jackson's Lord of the Rings trilogy was
disappointed by the 2006 film version
the movie had to condense a ludicrous
amount of plot to fit the running time
fans for the book were furious at what
was left out while unknowing audiences
were just plain confused
it was critically savaged in a
box-office disappointment and what could
have been the start of a new Fantasy
franchise ended up instead just a
gettable one off The Cat in the Hat
there's arguably no greater children's
author than dr. Seuss whose books
feature iconic artwork and a uniquely
playful vocabulary his work manages to
be timeless because it truly is for all
ages subtlety ought to be the name of
the game when adapting dr. Seuss but
2003's The Cat in the Hat is anything
but subtle starring Mike Myers as the
title trouble maker the humor is crude
and vulgar resembling Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas more than classic
children's literature that's why they
think into a bet to cut off both is move
[Music]
the set design does mirror Seuss a style
but what looks fun on paper becomes
garish and unsettling in live-action the
critical consensus was decidedly
negative and all the disturbing innuendo
still haunts viewers dreams
[Music]